Shawn is with us in Evansville Indiana
hey Sean how are you I'm good Devon you
better than I deserve what's up good I'm
in the Army Reserve in this past weekend
they told me that it was required that I
get a government travel card which is a
credit card that's in my name that I
will need to use for training purposes
to travel to training sites and for
accommodation and it is a highly
required right yeah that's what they
tell me that it's required and it's in
my name so I really don't want to get a
credit card you either get out of the
reserves or you will get a credit card
right okay all right that's something we
don't have a choice I mean that's you
know it's it's a ridiculous process that
they use I don't agree with it but it is
absolute they do not Bend on it I mean
we work with the military a lot we've
told them over and over this is stupid
but they don't listen to us right and we
teach a lot of military folks all around
the world how to get out of debt and
stay out of debt now here's the thing
you do there are specific allowable
expenses that are reimbursed okay very
specific they have very clear guidelines
on this don't put anything else on that
card but you will not be reimbursed
unless you use that card they actually
don't require you to use the card you
just can't get your money back for your
travel okay if you don't do it and so
you just set this thing aside and it's
like a million you know it's just like
one of the weapons they teach you on you
know you set it aside and lock it up and
you use it only in the way they tell you
to use it right it's that dangerous you
know yeah so you use it very carefully
and with all the the safety mechanisms
and all the training and do not use the
thing for anything that is not 100%
reimbursable by the military by their
guidelines if it's not that you can't
use this card for it cuz you're gonna
you're gonna get yourself in a mess and
it's just you know you're gonna shoot
yourself in the foot no pun intended so
um you know be careful be very
be very careful hey thanks for the call
we appreciate you joining us